the girag and experience your you'll you
lose one of the things and when you do
the math is that you lose your ability
to see what's smart and what's not smart
like you just you lose that what every
drug it's just not mad don't blame it I
met don't blame a madman I don't use it
with weed no but you lose it with the
heart of Arthur Cole q lu you get
delirious get your judgment is fucking
foiled that's what drugs do to you
judgment is fuckin off and you catch
yourself sometimes yeah like what the
fuck that I just do you know wow that's
the scary part about sometimes like what
the fuck action and that's what a lot of
people are looking for right a lot of
people are looking for this fucking big
burst of escape you know they're looking
for something that just blows the mat or
whatever the fuck their life is because
they're looking to just escape they
don't like life they don't like it and
well yeah man well you die and they want
to get high to escape escape reality you
know man we get it like your back hurts
your back hurts you hurt your back it
fucking hurts bro you gotta go to a
doctor you know the idea to the
butterfly sweep I left my thumb up I'm
the fucking guy landed on my head
Chihuahua my thumb hurt it didn't swell
up I think when I needed the drugs is
when my whole body was in pain and it's
not pain that you feel it's just this
pain and it's well it's also you did it
for so long your body became accustomed
to using beginning so in the beginning
why is the main reason we get down why
is the main reason a guy like you
handles you have pain in your life
growing up we all do
what made you different to not doing it
you know when you uh when you first get
involved in that your body hurts man mmm
I can't imagine no when I was 17 I go
home at the end of the night with I was
in school I don't go to school at 7:30
sophomore high school junior had to go
to school and I would come home and sit
in the corner in the dark with earphones
on with an eight-track Black Sabbath and
I just do coke till 3:00 in the movies
Christ's no drinking just do coke in the
dark what possesses you to do that Joe
rogue I don't know was it cuz I was a
junkie nah I was you know what I was in
so much pain what's in but pain covers
this huge thing when you're doing drugs
pain could be uh you know fuckin that
confusion
man shows up his confusion confusion
shows up his pain is what I'm saying to
you confused so I was 16 could be
emotional pain could be oh so she
doesn't have to be physical bodies in
pain I do it you know I talked to the
guy that talked to the kid I kidnapped
you know I call him a lot now I'm guilty
I'm really fucking guilty that because I
saw something when I kidnapped him that
it's not Joe Diaz
I saw him suffering I saw him at one
moment on the floor handcuffed and I
would never want that for me you know
I'm saying like I always dread that that
happens to a friend of mine for what I
did and I always felt bad I had him call
on the podcast and I apologized to him
and I always call him up and I called
him the I damn we're 12 and he told me
you know every time I talk to him he
tells me more about his life bro you
know what happened since I kidnapped him
I bumped into him in 94 I kidnapped him
in 87 I bumped into a 94 and I bought
coke from him he was all fucked up at
seta on Pearl Street down in Boulder and
then he never remembered I think he
blacked out that's how bad a shape he
was and I asked him the last but not
this time though at the time before I
asked him human me buy and blow from you
he goes I remember seeing it I remember
hate you the next day couldn't anybody
knock you the fuck out because I caught
him off guard he was at a bar all fucked
up I got some be some blows look who's
here the guy who kidnapped me
you got who kidnapped me but I called
you life's blow after after you
kidnapped him and before you apologized
for kidnapping see you later guys woman
I saw him at a bar on Pearl Street even
say I'm sorry I kidnapped Enoch that
night I just gave him a hug that's him
if he knew where I get some blow and
shit not that night he gave me a hug and
I always thought the bottom of when I
apologized I felt really bad I talked to
me I Danny he start telling me he's 50
he lives with his mother he had a heart
attack you know I could tell when I
talked to him on his pictures on
Facebook that he had a stroke you know I
was all from the blow bro sometimes he
calls me and I get saw he's drinking you
know mm-hmm and sometimes I feel real
guilty did I do this but then you know
I'm the type of guy don't play that shit
you know I don't play that shit at all
he was fucked up when I getting that
dope me a couple weeks before you know
how we got his whole thing started was
because he got a DUI fucked up some cars
went to bowl the hospital I'm
with hospital Boulder general and while
he was in there you know Boulder he was
hurt they left him in a room by himself
and he stole a bottle liquid cocaine he
jumped out the window okay and they
caught him when I was laid on the other
side of boat you steal a bottle liquor
cocaine from the hospital you already
got problem oh my god shit napping him
you know we laugh and we giggle me
kidnapping him it makes me feel like
maybe I contributed to that but I didn't
he had his own doom why didn't I get
fucked up you know I mean I got fucked
up in different ways I paid in different
ways because the guilt of me doing that
to a man fucking destroyed me you know I
like to fuck around you know I could do
something bad if somebody harms me but
even with jujitsu I just can't put my
form in somebody's face man I hate when
I have to lay on somebody like I'll
check on me go you okay bro you know I
love you right look at me no I know you
know it's funny so for me seeing him in
that corner I always have that guilt
that I tied him up
you